[Music]
welcome to the iron lords podcast
hello and welcome to another iron lords
podcast first look video
for our
game
healing spree uh this is pete's now
though here uh i'm gonna be adding a
video very shortly for this new game
called healing spree that is gonna be
coming out very very shortly
we were able to get a copy of it and
when i saw it i instantly said
i need to play this game
right now and i need to play with my
wife
now if any of you has ever seen my wife
and i play
overcooked or moving out or tools up or
any of those games you'll know that we
are fans of these types of games and the
reason why we're fans of these games is
because we end up doing ridiculously
stupid things that everyone should not
be doing in a video game and that would
be
throwing things
kicking things pushing people into pits
all those stupid things
and when i saw that this is gonna be a
medical game and it's gonna have
different layers on top of what it
normally is
i said to myself
i want in
so what we ended up doing was
we ended up i think it matters
getting this copy we ended up sitting
down i ended up playing on stream and we
had a bunch of fun with it
you could see my wife is in the bottom
left corner i'm in the bottom right
she's got the baby and a baby bjorn
that's how much we wanted to play it and
first thing let me give you let me give
you guys a little bit of an
overview of it
um
what this game is about is you are
one of two people trying to save the
world
against some evil virus man
which kind of was kind of scary because
of the time frame being that it is after
the pandemic but it's still good
so what we ended up doing was you have
to end up making medicine and making
people feel better and then getting them
out of your hospital
now we we intended to just play the
first couple of levels uh and uh we
ended up playing like
oh the full like
the full board and maybe like a couple
after that
and
i really really liked
how they ended up doing
the mixing of the medicines
the different ways to make the pills the
needle syringes
there's so many different layers to the
game
which
i never even thought of using the tomato
to make the brains
um using the tomatoes to make the ivy
bags
there's so many like i said there's so
many different layers um
you have to it's pretty much has
a very similar pres
premise overcooked which is you have to
make sure you make
your your objective which in this case
the people healthy
now
your people come from the ambulance this
is
the from the the first level was the
ambulance inside so you grab people from
the ambulance take them put them onto
the onto the stretchers
uh and you end up putting them onto the
medical tables once you come on the
medical tables
you use the stethoscope to figure out
what's wrong with them you go to the
medicines you make the medicines either
by grinding stuff or mixing stuff or or
grinding one thing grinding another
thing and mixing them together then
giving them the medicine
and then after that
then the end of their being happy daily
so
[Music]
they start increasing the difficulty
very very
slowly during those levels
the first four levels they weren't too
difficult because they had very
very much very little layers to it it
was
a person comes in
person is sick
give them medicine
they're out
the last level
i saw the difficulty jump
now the reason for that is because it
takes too long for you to walk around
the building
because
you don't have the wheelchair
so what's the next best way to do it
throw them through the window
so i actually would break the window
grab the patients that are
sick
chuck them through the window
put them on on the tables
check them
get them their medicines you get them
out
so
it kind of increased the difficulty and
kind of means you have to think outside
the box which i really really enjoyed
now
the
next level
uh the first level had a shootout going
on
and you ended up having
bad guys and good guys that are both
there
and we were helping the good guys
helping the bad guys and healing
everybody and getting them all out and
we're getting low points and we're
trying to figure out what we were doing
wrong but we were like
we're going to have to wait and we're
going to figure this out later because
we just don't have the time because the
baby was trying to get a little fussy
but i will say this
they added
the layer of the morgue bags
because i guess when people die you put
them in the morgue bags
you had the gun shots which if you got
shot you died
you lose points
the hygiene situation if you don't
keep yourself clean
you have to lose points
so you have all these little layers that
they ended up putting on top of it which
made it
a lot more difficult which i liked
i like it when games are a little more
difficult and you have to think outside
the box and use your brain
and they did it here
so
i thank you for that
now
if you look at the graphics it's pretty
standard
graphics for those types of games tomato
uh and
that was fine i liked it it was good
animations were good everything was
solid
uh the replay value on it
uh i would say that i'm gonna finish it
i enjoy playing these games
uh i know it's gonna be a lot of fun
when you play with new people too so
when you get some friends playing we'll
see how it goes the multiplayer still is
wasn't working because we only had a
beta copy uh so i'm hoping that is ready
for launch uh if not we understand make
sure it's working before you end up
making it live uh and i'm all for it uh
as for as for the audio and everything
it was fun it was good i enjoyed it so i
am very very happy with it uh if you're
looking for a fun saturday game to play
with the family
definitely go pick up healing spree okay
thank you again everybody for taking the
time to check out this video uh make
sure you uh you know click the subscribe
button here
my name is pete
also known as sneldo uh if you go down
below you can see my name and i have a
link to my twitter and uh by all means i
am on twitch seven day uh not seven days
a week five days it feels like seven
days away five days a week uh once once
in the morning once in the afternoon uh
where i should say the evening
every single day monday or friday
now though again
giving you guys first look at
healing spree okay love you all have a
fantastic rest of your week
like and subscribe see you later have
any comments leave them below
and then
[Music]
good job
dispose of this in the bin
[Music]
oh no
[Music]
i can't technically die because i'm in
hell i'm not sure about you though
are you kidding me
sleep is my only destiny
looks like god and the devil made a deal
and we got scammed
volunteered fun exciting
and how do we do that
first level
i guess this is the first
[Music]
bible
[Music]
oh didn't break ew
oh no
hello
thanks so much
you guys hear my amazing wife
she's sitting there playing with poop
now i'm filthy
and we're now in a negative pool deficit
yes because
you're playing with poop
oh i'm fine i'm fine
i'm fine
[Music]
all right we're in the positives
did a banker rank us around the corner
the green in the honeycomb
give me them
did you just die
or did the person just die oh my god
i died
because
the ambulance just
flexed
[Music]
regular green
oh my god
[Music]
that was pretty funny
[Music]
15 seconds let's get these last two
dudes done
double green
[Music]
is green on there
i think that they would
go up there with the guy in the right
i got i got him get ready for the next
guy
[Music]
need a blue dude
he's gotta get sprayed
[Music]
get ready for the next guy i got him
ridiculous
i'm going to need a spray down
so if you can put him up there
i'll wait for this gun spring down
[Music]
and green leaf i got him
officer go back to uh
doing what you're doing
everything will be okay here
perfectly
care of that
i am uh hurting
injury cleaned
good
we are
and you were doing really really well in
my opinion
[Music]
i think i'm sorry they're done
oh
we're supposed to flush them
[Music]
rocking this
we only got one heart for that
[Music]
you